now uh the fact that words in English
have um a stress and they keep it in uh
connected
speech creates a specific Rhythm of the
language now uh if say the sentence for
example uh I would
say I would say a normal
speed Marcus bought a bag in Paris now
if I say Marcus bought a bag in Paris
and I say it quickly at normal
speed your brain especially when you're
learning
English doesn't have the time to process
the single
Parts but if you focus if I say it very
slowly or your goal is to focus on the
single
Parts you will hear that I say Mark has
bought a bag in
Paris has bought a bag in
Paris I don't know how this works can I
do this
no so if you see here
it's so we have here
mark it doesn't work anymore
wait so you have Mark has and then you
have
bought a bag in Paris so you have as you
can see this is called a
stress it's every single sentence has
this kind of configuration which is
Alter alternating ups and
downs so if you consider for
example how I don't know any one of you
want to read this
one
go on joh has been trying to call here
for hours okay now as you can see it
John has been trying to call you for
hours so
hours this
one this is your
City on Moscow is really an incredible
City yeah Moscow you you have to say
pronounce it Moscow is really an
incredible City
okay